more Saachi more water
look I know your boss is selling on the
black more people our employees so
legitimate businessman sure sure
we're all legitimate in a bar and okay I
know it for I am Hancock - one - it's a
shipping container there was a corpse in
a box wearing a mask with a dragon
burned onto its chest I'm gonna talk to
the men who sent it an important Randall
never heard of him look give no idea how
hard it's been attract on your boss from
Hong Kong to Kuala Lumpur that mess in
Jakarta
a shipment was stolen from my employers
warehouse in Jakarta things went
sideways
Wow
look you really don't want to mess with
me what if I disagree then you have to
deal with him oh you said you had this
handled ward
we can't know the future not completely
our employer won't seize the property
back well friend I'll let you feel that
one
you
you mean these
don't try that again
I once believed that justice could be
found in a court of law in the light of
day
but I was fooling myself darkness only
responds to darkness
[Applause]
[Music]
the truth is I'd rather die as the dough
than what it is Matt Murdock
[Music]
everybody it's Charlie I've been getting
a lot of requests to do a video for the
ending of iron fist season 2 so I'll
explain what's going on we're still
doing that spider-man ps4 giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so big thing here obviously is
that word Meechum into any R and R in
Japan looking for Orson Randall from the
iron fist comics and Danny has his guns
and fires Qi bullets quick ketchup Danny
loses the power of the iron fist Davos
takes it from him but when they get it
back
Danny realizes that he needs to study
the history of the iron fist in order to
do that he needs to seek out Orson
Randall but he can't do that while he is
the iron fist
because whoever holds the fist needs to
stay in New York City and protect it
charged by Matt protect my city so
Danny's free at the end of the season to
go off and look Ward goes with him but
earlier in the season
someone ships Davos a corpse of a
previous version of iron fist we never
found out who that body was we just
learned that it was an old iron fist
that died a long time ago we find out
that it was actually Orson Randall that
shipped the body to Davos so either he
was working with Davos or just being
really shady you don't know you just
know that Orson Randall has all this
information but if you're not a big
comic book reader
Orson Randall is sort of like the world
war 1 era iron fist what happened was is
when his mother was still pregnant with
him his father's airship crashed in
Kunlun so Orson Randall was born in
Conlan he eventually was raised to
become the next iron fist
he went on a bunch of adventures he
participated in World War one but when
he was called back to Conlan to fight in
the immortal weapons tournament he
refused to because he said he'd seen too
much death in the world so he fled with
the book of the iron fist which is their
entire history it's like a wiki on all
their powers their abilities in the life
history of every single version of iron
fist so the whole idea of season 3 is
that they're going to explain that Orson
is probably going to give Danny the book
that only iron fists can read there's
something special about the way they
channel their Chi that allows them to
actually read the book the cool thing
about the guns that links back to
Colleen wing is is that we find this is
actually big comic book
Colleen wing is a descendant of woo
aoshi who is the first woman to ever
become iron fist they called her to the
pirate queen of pink hi BAE who would
rain down lightning from God on her
enemies so what happens is is that Orson
Randall because he had the book of the
iron fist learned how to channel his Chi
from woo eh oh she's tail
in the book she would channel her Chi
through a bow into arrow so it would
look like it was literally raining down
she arrows which is why they called it
lightning from God so that's how he came
up with the idea for the Chi bullets but
that's also on the path to Dany learning
how to light up both of his fists and if
you're a big Korra fan and you remember
Jinora learning how to energy Bend
imagine Dany learning to use his Chi
more like that more like energy bending
he can even light up his entire body
once he becomes fully actualized but in
order to do that he has to learn from
somebody or from the book and that
requires Orson Randle so if you were
confused about why Colleen Wing is
linked to the history of the iron fist
it's because of that coin that was on
her ancestors box so it's a family
heirloom that has her family crest on it
but on the other side of the emblem it
has the symbol of the iron fist because
the wood that was used to create the box
was taken from the bow of whooee oh
she's pirate ship for those of you that
are wanting the immortal weapons the
crane sisters are just a teaser for a
crane mother but their appearance is
probably a hint that we're going to see
the other capital cities of heaven in
future seasons hopefully next season
we'll see if you want to read up on that
it's pretty much all in Matt Fraction
and Edie Brubaker's iron fist run is
great Horace and Randall is a really
cool character I can't wait to see who
they cast as him the daredevil teaser
which I already did a video about when
Netflix posted on their official account
they just wrote Jobe 12:22 and it's a
Bible verse because Matt is a devout
Catholic so daredevil Catholicism so it
reads he reveals the deep things of
darkness and brings utter darkness into
the light which is a reference to
daredevil dragging the kingpin into the
light kingpin is the darkness matt is
supposed to be the light so even though
the teaser is really dark he's like I
would rather die as the devil than live
as Matt Murdock the Bible verse that
Netflix posted is a little more
optimistic about the
way the season is going to end so I
think you know eventually we'll get to
the point where he can balance both
personas but for the majority of the
season he will probably leave the map
Murdock persona behind and just be the
devil of Hell's Kitchen so let me know
in the comments what do you think about
Iron Fist season 2 and what are you most
hype about for daredevil season 3
remember they're gonna bring the trailer
for that to New York Comic Con so I'll
do a video about that as soon as they
drop new stuff while you wait for
everything click here for my new phase
for Captain Britain video and click here
for my Captain Marvel Secret Invasion
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight